there's a reason the carpet at this New
York City premiere is blue the studio
behind this new series isn't Universal
or Paramount Pictures it's Walmart don't
look at me
like like
[Music]
that Walmart says this isn't a typical
romcom it's ROM Commerce just decided
this is so mean and it's called ad to
Heart viewers can buy those items and
over 330 others directly from Walmart
while watching the series on Tik Tok
Roku and YouTube this is a big bet for
us here's why Walmart and other
companies are investing in so-called
shoppable content even though the trend
has yet to take off in the
US the series follows the typical
holiday romcom plot City girl returns to
her hometown and bumps into an old flame
Jess ja there's a little bit of
cheesiness within a romantic comedy of
course there's nothing cheesy in the
selling and it feels very seamless and
natural and how it comes together on TI
Tok each 3-minute episode runs as a paid
infeed ad featuring 10 shoppable product
tiles Roku users see an ad on their home
screen which takes them to the series
playlist while watching they can shop
for products by pressing okay on their
Roku remote babe can I come out now this
allows users to text themselves a link
to shop on their phone on YouTube users
can find a link to all the products in
the description box you like this I'm
packing for my Miami trip almost
everything in the 23 part series from
the outfits to the decor is from Walmart
products were chosen from things that
are giftable things that we think are
really on trend for the season if they
wanted to see the jacket and then also
the outfit under it it might be like we
come into the scene with the jacket and
then we take it off it is 10° outside
what did you think there's a shot it's
in the trailer with like walking up to
the
door that was an example of a scene
where we had to really get it right like
the placement of the shoes had to be
very exact merry Christmas babe to to
measure consumer engagement Walmart
looks at three things one are people
adding the item to their cart who
proposes after 6 months does he even
know your middle name two are they
buying it and three if they're not
buying it do they come back to it later
if the scoop boots was something that
you added to your cart but then
abandoned but then went and bought them
in store later we consider that
inspiration moment happening from the
content that they first saw there ad to
heart is the newest iteration of what
Walmart calls its social commerce
strategy the company has also partnered
with NBC Universal to create a shoppable
experience in season 8 of Bravo's
reality show below deck Mediterranean on
peacock what do you mean I'm not on top
you're obviously not during ad breaks
viewers get served and ad for a Walmart
product similar to the one they just saw
in the show and they can buy it using
the QR code on screen let's get Merry
and bright other companies like Home
Depot have also dabbled in this space
let's get to decorating it created a
shoppable series called Merry and bright
where viewers can buy items using
integrated QR
codes and a number of companies have
been using Tik tok's video shopping ads
which launched last year you have every
player in the ecosystem thinking we have
to be able to unlock more shopping
activity Christopher vulmer is a
managing director at media link a media
and marketing consulting firm Walmart is
a media link client vulmer however does
not personally advise Walmart you've got
media companies that are trying to
unlock new sources of revenue and you've
got Brands and retailers that are trying
to be where all the attention is which
is social media platforms and streaming
vulmer says Apple's privacy change in
2021 that restricted how users are
tracked also triggered many companies to
move away from cookie based ads what
they're trying to do now is build up
much more of a first-party data
relationship with consumers and actually
push them more and more to their own
environments where they can enact a
transaction and build more of a
long-term relationship shoppable content
is popular in China but is still in its
early days in the US it has been a
slower ramp in the US but it is
definitely ramping it's taking off a
little bit more with younger Generations
first and I think we're just developing
the norms and the routines and uh the
Behavior Uh here in the US right now the
content has to be great it can be a
fantastic user experience but if it's
not embedded in a story that users find
very compelling very interesting it's
not going to be something that they come
back to hobby I have something to tell
you
Walmart didn't share any data about its
social commerce efforts do not get me
started about the color of this bag but
white says there's been more traffic to
the Walmart site and increased sales I
think we'll pick up a lot of learnings
along the way that will continue to
inform and help us progress down this
shoppable journey Mr Bogle is it
possible to add a stop at Walmart on the
way
[Music]
absolutely